okay so starting a game playing a quest
to 3,000 feet a master who I I'm I'm
friendly with in real life and good luck
let's play what's the play here let's
play 96 and I'll have the chat room open
just in case there's any emergency but
this will be new
there's no twitch chat to distract me
just me and my thoughts and my pieces
okay I'll play you six I had this this
position recently in a tournament in
Montreal against FN dog Eckert's who
played like c3 and then I played Bishop
b4 against g3 I'll play d5 this is why
okay layouts okay I'm gonna close at
least minimize stream maps of yes yeah
against Bishop g2 I usually take we have
some sort of cattle on ready type thing
there's a few moves here for for whites
when a4 is one of the moves actually one
of my games against fiddler went down
the slide i plundered really early in
the middle game but okay this is this is
longer chess I trying to avoid
blundering typically the main idea for
black is to play there should be seven
complete development and eventually c5
if I can get in c5 without any issues
and I gets a long way to equalize but
opponent taking time this is casual so
I'm not risking any any rating points by
rating did taken tip recently Queen b3
is a move yeah with Queen b3 there's
some more pressure I'll still play
Bishop e7 only reasonable square for the
[ __ ]
I think more popular as Queen c2 with
Queen b3 there's a for ideas okay I'll
play Knight my bt7 very often if white
does play a four okay a six
just keep things defended so d4 it is a
question like what move order to play
I'm wondering if my opponent did any
specific preparation for me I think a
six don't make sense to at least
consider playing c5 next move this is
another difference with Queen on unbe
three is constant pressure ins b5 so a
six over defends b5 I want to play c5
and if I get in c5 then the queen is
exploitable is there c4 ideas but should
d5 Knight c-5m one move might be 95 here
having a lot of memories from this
fiddler game or at some points in this
fiddler game I I had Castle I played
Queen b6 and I played 95 and I just
allowed Knight takes d7
okay so 95 95 unleashes a bishop pawn is
pinned I mean I could just take I could
take in 95 and it concedes a bishop
error that's one approach
there's also I mean there's takes and
isn't this what I just said takes takes
95 idea to play see 5 the next move
another approach is Queen b6 but I'd be
concerned about Bishop e3 yeah a lot of
bad memories from this one's fiddler
game
yeah I'm mainly focusing I'm taking in
95 because then I'm threatening c5
immediately there is e4 there's rook t1
with e4 then lights
I probably drops back and then rook to
e1 Queen c7 it's hard to stop c5 even if
Bishop e3 you see five c4 e four will
shut down this Bishop so let's take if
somehow light can stop me from playing
c5 then I'll be worse I'm not sure how
that's possible Knight c3 another move
I'm curious what light will do here
because there's Knight c3 e4 and routine
one I think are the main considerations
also a 4 a 4 might actually stop d5 I'm
looking at it more closely a 4 C 5 takes
okay so Rick do you want immediately so
initially I just thought Queen c7 which
looks very reasonable calculating Queen
c7 a for c5 takes and then c4
this is Queenie for their 2496 it's a
little bit messy
okay Queen I mean Queen c7 attacks upon
okay some initiative
giving white some options I'm a little
bit lagging with development like I'm
nots
I haven't develop my bishop or Castle
but that should come soon and white
still has to develop a queen side yeah
overall I think it's more up to a white
to can improve what to do in the
position because my next several moves
are quite natural the question if white
wants to play for was a force probably
reasonable I should calculate a for c5
takes and then c4 please try and
calculate more accurately because Queen
a 496 it's Queen e5
unusual position I mean maybe that works
a 4 C 5 Jake C 424 I'm drawing arrows to
help the people in the future watching
the arrows are sometimes a little bit
distracting for me okay I guess with a
for though I'm not obliged to play c5 oh
I could just take on e5 I've forgotten
I'm threatening five so Knight c3 okay
oh so maybe the stop c5 as well that
might see three hmm I guess I didn't
conserve this because I can just win
upon mmm do I go for greed winn-dixie
five free pawn in Queen xe5 where is
White's compensation if we trade on d5 I
probably take the e pawn there's Bishop
f4 Queen f6 because there's efore and
then we could take with the C pawn as
well it takes takes takes Bishop f4 and
I even take on e too
he was looking for like a worst-case
scenario I don't have to calculate so
much take six takes I guess he for ISM
move right away I went another pawn and
Bishop f4 that's a question can i castle
soon enough they queen h5 we need to try
Brooksie one will turn rook c7 and am
bishop d5 in the end i think i should
take
I think it's really up to white to prove
things like in most of these lines I I
spend time looking for whites resources
or searching for whites resources I'm
more just kind of relying on intuition
that I shouldn't be in so much trouble
I might be misjudging things I mean okay
I I want to center pawn whites gonna
have a little bit of initiative with the
e4 and with the Bishop a4 ideas if I for
right away I have Bishop c5 which could
be very nice okay so let's expect it I
think yeah and my impression was to take
with the pawn now I'm realizing
realizing after takes Bishop f4 takes
his rook e1 but I have Queen c4 should
be fine
okay let's see what happens I mean II
four and Bishop f4 I think are the two
candidate moves for whites maybe slow
playing maybe like this or this to
prepare this try and prevent me from
developing my bishop
I think if let's imagine Bishop here
Bishop d6 Bishop t4 I have Queen g5
defending the pawn a 4 is another idea I
think this type of position I have to be
like hyper aware of of White's ideas but
with a four eye before
okay pawn you for yeah there's some
pressure here for sure I think this is
what I was looking at earlier should
probably devoted some more time to this
line because Bishop f4 is coming another
pawn sack so takes Bishop f4 and Queen
each five so what I had calculated
earlier I think it's still holding up or
it takes Bishop f4 Queen h5 rook c1 and
then I have vision d5 which shuts down
the D file a tax a queen to watch out d7
potential meeting square but it's hard
for white to access so pawn takes e4
Bishop f4 Queen h5
as a greediness paying off I'm really
not considering like other candidate
moves I'm just focused on this line
because it works for me and then I don't
think there's much else to consider
takes [ __ ] before Queen h5 in it's nice
that I have some a vague attack against
her rook and the pollen supported on e4
also the Queen supports c5 for the
bishop in some cases imagining even like
takes Bishop f4 queen h5 rook c1 Bishop
c5 yeah I think there's enough
let's take spending a lot of time
actually but I think if I survive the
next whatever five moves and don't get
like so worse and it should be should be
good for me h5 I mean what else seconds
fairy with the Queen
yeah so I saw this position coming a
while ago and sometimes it's hard to
judge from far away realizing there's
some resource like in the slide rook c1
Bishop e5 Queen c3 some ideas of queen
c1 also the queen hits upon sin the
bishop maybe has a harder time
developing so I should really focus my
efforts on on Roxy 1 but after mmm let's
say after Bishop e5 Queens he threw the
the rekon seen once tied down to the
rock on d1 not sure if I can exploit
that but okay Brooke c1 I also saw
Bishop c5 there's Queen c3 hmm
Queen c3 double attacks
I think the concerning move in these
variations is Queen c3
I'm not seeing a clear-cut solution
unless I have another idea
oh I have interesting idea rook c1
Bishop e7 rook c7 was a main concern but
then I am Bishop d5 and then there's no
Queen C 3 because this move so there
should be seven I read I've rejected
earlier because it allows rook c7 it
might be might be risky but it deserves
attention he's a Viking Castle and not
lose a bishop that would be how would be
ideal so just Bishop e7
yeah this is my mean like I've ambition
t5 lines are actually a bit more murky
but Bishop e7 clear intention rook c7
Bishop d5 then the Queen's tied down to
this rook
there's Queen c2 Queen c2 interesting
Queen c2 bishop d8
okay so I'll draw arrows um
rook c7 her sorry there should be seven
Oryx eSATA and vision d5 Queen c2
looking for tactics to distract the
Queen I'd want a castle but it hangs a
bishop so I'd played Bishop d8 first
hitting the rook preparing to castle I'm
not lose back a pawn but White's not
actually if I need to take as the
Queen's overworked and the work doesn't
really have any great squares I don't
think there's worth g7 but I don't think
that's too scary
there's Bishop d6 too but then I can
take in castle okay there's a b7 yeah a
lot of these types of positions require
a lot of kind of concretes calculations
and playing the defensive side it's more
about like survival and really being
aware of upon this ideas another idea
that I've just kind of forgot about is
g4 a g4 I don't think I'm too afraid of
the thing I just take that gives me
initiative
okay so rook c7 oh I forgot about ripped
a c7 well that's not sacking a lot of
material and the bishop on d5 will cut
off the roof I don't think I'm getting
needed there
yeah like takes takes I should have
looked at this previously I mean White
has one check and Keeney eights I lose
casting rights but I'd be up the
exchange and two pawns but maybe I mean
rook see one it's interesting still idea
work c7 turned to me me so route 67
takes Queen before maybe King King g7
okay Queen c2 makes me happy yeah
because now I can play Bishop TAS am
bishop d8 yeah the rook is actually very
limited yeah I had said rook d7 I'm not
not castle yet so I can just take it I
mean White's probably gonna try and win
back upon just making sure there's no
crazy like Queen c6 ideas rook takes d5
I can take with Queen
Bishop to g5 but that's I don't think
that's you could deserve some
calculation there's a g8 our Bishop
takes e4 I meant it takes e4 I think I
can just take the Queen side down to the
rook oh there's rook c5 Merc c5 okay I
can keep throwing punches
I think the bishops do well to restricts
White's attack also with rook c5 I could
Castle and Misha Daisy before I take
back because I hit the queen Wow
oh I forgot the the things aligned ooh
oh did I just blunder I forgot my rocks
hanging an end
Oh No
don't tell me I'm losing I might be
losing this Bishop diggsy for I've any
escape takes takes takes so takes takes
thinking about takes then there's takes
woo oh this is dangerous
Wow I completely forgot my rook is
aligned I don't have my queen has no
moves to man what to do
wait a minute oh no that doesn't work
scene Queen takes takes now I can't
trying to look for ways to salvage
material Queen d1 no like i'll
temporarily be up
that's your feel but it's not going to
help me okay so the problem with this is
Queen c6 and Queen takes 8 I'm just
losing otherwise I have to take with
Queen Bishop takes e4 and I work on 8
and the end like castle at some points
it may be castle at some point Wow okay
let's take with I don't have a plan
though takes with Queen rook c8 I
probably just have to accept that this
is losing theirs Queen some eventual
Queen check on d1
I'm searching but not finding much to do
when takes 8 to know 27 6 takes
I'm looking at this line now takes King
f8 I lose a ruck I have Queen d1 check
but I'm just I'm just losing any other I
mean this is very close to just resign
of all the other moves one more idea
actually like five at some points so
Queen d4 Queen c6 King f8 Queen takes
even like g5 okay let's take and then
queen g4 that's ugly but I what to do
and if I take taking doesn't help Wow
Queen if I play g5 it doesn't really
help either
looking at taking the classic green sign
that gets mated that's by 24
so queen c6 expected I think I mean
there's a line like take stakes where
white has to bishops for a pawn but yeah
this is unfortunate oh I'm just getting
maida here takes takes should be seven
doesn't help okay Wow nice game I got
punished for being greedy less than 23
moves nice game well played pretty much
yeah
something terribly wrong
I just miss rotate d5 got way too
comfortable I was even talking about
this kink aware of my pawns resources
there's you be southern probably and
just not a good move
maybe it's already questionable